[Música]
desfiles militares banderas en los
nacionales con un gran despliegue las
fuerzas armadas la monarquía y el
ejecutivo celebraron el día de la
hispanidad este 12 de octubre
reivindiquemos lo que nos une lo que nos
engrandece como sociedad lo que hace de
españa un país acogedor abierto diverso
una jornada que como a los americanos
también divide a la sociedad española
cada 2 de octubre el país conmemora la
llegada de cristóbal colón al continente
americano a pesar de las atrocidades
cometidas contra los pueblos indígenas
como masacres y abusos sexuales algo por
lo que muchos se niegan a celebrar que
vamos a celebrar
nosotros creemos que nadie debería
celebrar ni festejar esta fecha lo que
se debería hacer a estas alturas es un
reconocimiento del daño causado de los
errores cometidos porque lo que llevó el
imperio español a nuestros pueblos no
fue civilización y progreso fue un
régimen de terror fue un régimen de
barbarie pero la ultraderecha y la
derecha del país sostienen que no hay
nada de qué arrepentirse y han llegado a
asegurar que trajeron en la civilización
al continente declaraciones que
pretenden reescribir la historia feliz
día de la hispanidad la mayor obra de
hermanamiento cultural que puso fin al
genocidio entre pueblos indígenas y
trajo el mestizaje de españa y américa
por esta razón y en medio de la polémica
méxico ha pedido a españa ya la iglesia
católica que pidan perdón por las
atrocidades cometidas